hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today I thought was actually going to be
a video on the executions I happen to
get that wrong so on the last couple
videos we talked about there was gonna
be a road map and they showed the road
map and on the 23rd there was content
and I presume that it was going to be
executions as what the usual trend it's
usually a week or two before the season
starts is when they've released the
executions and I guess maybe due to the
virus pushing the whole season back
maybe they're waiting for the executions
to release a little bit before the
season or maybe because of the virus
they didn't actually get to finish the
executions we don't know they never
stated anything but at the moment that
is not the topic of discussion for today
that's for another video in the future
today's gonna be about the current
content of the week which is actually a
whole new material it's very similar to
the white material that we got before
where there is no rep requirement it's
just a ten thousand steel purchased per
hero so it's gonna get very very pricey
the more heroes you buy this for but
it's a new material called rose gold
obviously there's different variations
of the name depending on the faction
that you look at but it's pretty much
just a rose gold pink kind of color and
I must say that I'm gonna be showing
these throughout the entire video for
every single hero so you can see what
they look like but I must say do not
take these at face value throughout the
video some of the armors I show might be
the default armor some of it might be
the high rank armor and some of the
armor that I showcase with this new
material show off the color this pink
quite a bit but some of it doesn't show
what at all and it seems like it's not
even there to begin with so I urge you
to go into your games once you've
finished this video to check your mains
armor and see how it looks with your
specific character set up an armor and
not just mine because it might look
drastically different depending on the
armor that you pick but what that is
always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started with today's video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you